lot of holidays celebrating might be
happening at home this year
well you can still ring in the
festivities looking fabulous
and comfortable at the same time style
expert brittany levine has everything to
help you party in style this season
even if it doesn't go beyond your
kitchen or dining room hey brittany
how's it going
great to see you jc yes i've got some
fabulous items here and we have to kick
it off because before you begin
i'm all about the fragrances and you
have to smell good when you're around
your family members of course
yes so we have the carolina herrera this
is the good girl supreme holiday set i
love all these holiday sets
and it really has those beautiful aromas
in here
and reinvents the contrast of life and
shadows
i love the fact that it's a shoe you
also get a body cream and a little shoe
here so for all the ladies
this is from macy's dot com but 135
and then for our men can't leave them
out this is the paco
avon okay this is their one million
holiday set this year so this is under a
hundred
it really defies all the rules i like to
say when it comes to men's
fragrances with notes of amber leather
tangerine really really stunning and it
looks really high-end too
and you also have a new passion project
for us this year what's the passion
project we're talking about
yes we do so this is from hat
not hate it's an anti-bullying campaign
so from
you're seven years old to 97 years old
you can actually
knit two blue hats that really show up
for anti-bullying
and it's all 24.99 it comes with this
whole kit right here and it's very easy
because jc i can't do this stuff but i
can actually
do this when it comes to knitting and
they're doing some fabulous things
and of course yeah go ahead but also too
puzzles were a big thing at the
beginning of the year we couldn't find
puzzles and now you have some cool
puzzles for us
that is true puzzles are finally back in
stock
this is from a great site modcloth.com
they have great games there
all for the holidays this season and i
love the fact that they've got cactuses
they've got a thousand piece puzzles all
about 12 to 28
so great finds there and it is the
holidays we have to keep toasty and cozy
at the same time what do you have for us
yes i am loving the styles from cool
libera by
ugg really great everyday essentials
we're so
comfortable we're seeing this fuzz buzz
to
end here that's something that it's fuzz
and two excuse me
that has that little back strap back
here these great slip and styles for
both men and women and the best part
about these under a hundred dollars
it is perfect last question really fast
like 10 seconds the shoe the fragrance
shoe the heel
is it wearable once you use it or is it
done is it just for fragrance
you throw that in your bag you can't
wear that shoe you can't do it all right
perfect well brittany thank you so much
for joining us we truly appreciate it
thank you guys thank you